OFFICIAL WOULD WANT TO FOCUS ON
THE ACTUAL THREATS.
>> JOINING ME NOW, BRANDON JUDD.
HE'S THE PRESIDENT OF THE
NATIONAL BORDER PATROL UNION,
MARK KERKORIAN AND SEMAN NESARY.
BRANDON, I WANT TO START WITH
YOU.
YOU WERE PART OF THE WHITE HOUSE
MEETING THAT ENDED WITH
INFORMATION ALONG THE BORDER.
IS THIS AN INVENTED THREAT THAT
MANY IN THE MEDIA ARE SAYING?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
GATHERING IN TIJUANA THAT ARE
WAITING TO COME ACROSS THE
BORDER.
THE THREATS THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO STORM THE PORTS OF ENTRY,
IT'S A SIGN THAT THEY DON'T CARE
ABOUT OUR LAWS, THEY'RE GOING TO
DO WHAT THEY NEED TO DO FOR
THEIR OWN BENEFIT INSTEAD OF
DOING IT IN A LEGAL MANNER.
WHEN I WAS IN THAT MEETING, WHAT
I SAW, I SAW AN UNWAVERING
DETERMINATION TO SECURE THE
BORDER FOR THE AMERICAN PUBLIC,
FOR THE SAFETY OF THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC.
WE APPRECIATE THAT AND
APPRECIATE THAT DETERMINATION
THE PRESIDENT HAS.
>> AND YOUR REACTION, SEMAN.
THIS IS THE HEAD OF THE BORDER
UNION.
HE KNOWS WHAT'S GOING ON THERE.
YOUR REACTION?
>> AND I THINK THAT THE
CONVERSATION SHOULDN'T BE SO
MUCH ABOUT THE CARAVAN BUT THE
CARAVAN SHEDS LIGHT THAT OUR
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM IS BROKEN.
THE FACT THAT THIS IS A REAL
THREAT IS 5,000 PEOPLE COMING TO
THE BORDER, SEEKING ASYLUM.
WHY IS THAT -- WHY ISN'T THE
SYSTEM THE ISSUE?
THESE PEOPLE HAVE NOT RUSHED THE
BORDER.
NOBODY HAS SEEN THEM HURT
ANYBODY.
SO WHY ARE WE MAKING THE PEOPLE
ESCAPING THEIR PROBLEMS THE
ISSUE?
WHY DON'T WE TRY TO CRITICIZE
THE IMMIGRATION SYSTEM AND FIX
THAT PROBLEM?
>> LET'S HOLD IT THERE A MINUTE,
SAMAN.
THERE'S ABUSES OF THE ASYLUM
SYSTEM GOING ON.
ASYLUM IS BECAUSE YOU'RE UNDER
PERSECUTION, NOT JUST BECAUSE
YOU WANT A GEORGE.
MARK?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
I'D SAY THAT THE BROADER SYSTEM
IS THE PROBLEM.
THE SYSTEM IS WE HAVE ASYLUM
RULES THAT INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE TO
MAKE THESE BOGUS ASYLUM CLAIMS
ESSENTIALLY USE ASYLUM AS A
STRATEGY FOR IMMIGRATION.
NONE OF THESE PEOPLE HAVE A
REALISTIC EXPECTATION OF GETTING
POLITICAL ASYLUM AT THE END OF
THE DAY.
THEY'RE DOING THIS TO APPLY FOR
ASYLUM AS A WAY OF GETTING
PASSED THE BORDER AND THEN
THEY'RE HOME FREE.
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON SINCE THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WHO
INCENTIVIZED IT AND WE'RE STILL
DEALING WITH THE FALLOUT FROM
IT.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE THIS CARAVAN
AND OTHER CARAVANS THAT ARE
DOING THE SAME THING.
>> THIS IS KIRSTJEN NIELSEN
ALONG THE BORDER.
LISTEN.
>> THE REALITY IS, THERE'S
CURRENTLY OVER 6,200 INDIVIDUALS
CAMPED OUT SOUTH OF THE U.S.
BORDER IN TIJUANA TODAY AS I
STAND HERE.
IN MEXICALI, THERE'S MORE THAN
3,000 CARAVAN MEMBERS.
THE TWO GROUPS COMBINED WITH
OTHER CARAVANS MAKING THEIR WAY
THROUGH MEXICO WILL RESULT IN
PRESIDENT 8,000 TO 10,000
MIGRANTS AMASSING ALONG OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
THE CRISIS IS REAL AND IT'S ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THIS WALL.
>> YOUR REACTION.
I WANT TO GO TO BRANDON JUDD.
>> AGAIN, IF YOU LOOK AT THIS,
THIS IS NOT ABOUT LEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
IT'S ABOUT ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
THOSE PEOPLE ARE NOT GOING TO
WAIT UNTIL THEY GO THROUGH THE
PORTS OF ENTRY.
THEY WILL CROSS ILLEGALLY.
THE FIRST ACT THAT THEY MAKE IN
THE UNITED STATES IS AN ILLEGAL
ACT.
THAT SHOULD MAKE EVERYBODY A
LITTLE BIT CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT
IS MOTIVES ARE.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE CRIMINAL
ELEMENT HERE?
THEY CLAIM THEY HAVE 500
CRIMINALS AS PART OF THESE
CARAVANS.
SAMAN, DOES THAT SAY TO YOU TO
LET THEM IN UNDER THE ASYLUM
LAW?
>> THAT'S THE WRONG
CHARACTERIZATION OF THE
ARGUMENT.
THESE --
>> IT'S NOT A CHARACTERIZATION.
>> IT IS.
>> NO, IT'S WHAT HOMELAND --
THIS IS WHAT --
>> THERE'S NO EVIDENCE OF THAT.
>> SO KIRSTJEN NIELSEN IS LIE
SOMETHING.
>> NO.
THEY ISSUED A MEMO SAYING WE
NEED TO WORK WITH MEXICO TO VET
THESE PEOPLE, KEEP THEM IN
MEXICO, GO THROUGH THE ASYLUM
PROCESS THERE AND TAKE IT ON A
CASE BY CASE BASIS AND SO WHO
QUALIFIES.
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE OR NO PROOF
THAT THESE GUYS WILL SHOW UP TO
THE PORT OF ENTRY AND BUM RUSH
IT AND BECOMING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
THEY'RE COMING TO SEEK ASYLUM.
SOME OF THEM REALLY DO HAVE A
VERY PLAUSIBLE CASE.
UNFORTUNATELY THEY GET WASHED UP
WITH THE ONES BECAUSE THEY WANT
A BETTER JOB.
THE TRUTH IS, THERE'S A HANDFUL,
A FEW HUNDRED OF THEM THAT HAVE
A GOOD CASE THAT ARE LIVING IN
BAD CONDITIONS THAT HAVE SEEN
PEOPLE GET MURDERED, THAT HAVE
HAD FAMILY MEMBERS GETS
MURDERED.
I TURN AWAY A DOZEN PEOPLE THAT
SAY I CAN'T HELP YOU.
BUT EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE
SOMEBODY DOES HAVE A GOOD CASE.
>> THERE'S NO DOUBT THE ASYLUM
LAWS NEED TO BE RE-VISITED.
WE CAN'T -- MY FATHER WAITED A
YEAR IN LINE BEFORE HE HAD HIS
PAPERS RECOGNIZED.
THEN HE CAME WITH A SPONSOR AND
THEN SERVED IN THE MILITARY.
THANK YOU, GENTLEMEN, FOR YOUR
CONTRIBUTION.
HERE NOW TO EXPLORE WHETHER THE
PRESIDENT HAS THE CONSTITUTIONAL
AUTHORITY TO USE U.S. TROOPS TO
PROTECT THE BORDER AND ON
AMERICAN SOIL, THE BORDER
AGENTS, WE'RE JOINED BY DONALD
CRAMER.
A FORMER INTELLIGENCE OFFICER
AND IRAQ VETERAN, JOEL RUBEN,
FORMER OBAMA SECRETARY OF STATE.
JOEL,YOU BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT
WAS WRONG BECAUSE OF THE UNCLEAR
MISSION.
BUT ISN'T PROTECTING THE
SOUTHERN BORDER AND ENFORCING
STANDING IMMIGRATION LAWS
MISSION ENOUGH?
>> WELL, RAY, THERE'S NO
MISSION.
THERE'S NO MILITARY MISSION
HERE.
THERE'S NO CLARITY ABOUT THE END
POINT, WHAT THE OBJECTIVES WILL
BE.
EVEN IF THERE'S A TECHNICAL
ABILITY OF THE PRESIDENT TO SEND
THE TROOPS THERE, IT'S A BAD
JUDGMENT.
THIS PRESIDENT HAS A HABIT OF
USING OUR TROOPS AS POLITICAL
PROBLEMS AND THAT WAS THE INTENT
FOR THIS PRIOR TO THE MID-TERMS
TO TURN OUT THE VOTE.
THE TROOPS ARE DOING NOTHING,
WAITING.
DOING SUPPORT.
WE HAVE CIVILIAN ENFORCEMENT
THAT CAN DO THE JOB.
WE DON'T NEED OUR TROOPS THERE.
>>
>> Laura:
>> DOES THE PRESIDENT HAVE THE
AUTHORITY HERE?
>> THESE SOLDIERS AND SOURCES,
THEY'RE NOT LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS.
HE DOES HAVE THE RIGHT TO DEPLOY
THEM.
IT'S HIS RIGHT AS
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF TO SUPPORT
THIS COUNTRY, WHETHER IT'S IN
HUMANITARIAN AID OR SUPPORTING
THE BORDERS.
PRESIDENT DID IT, PRESIDENT
REAGAN DID IT, PRESIDENT BUSH
DID IT.
IT'S HIS RIGHT AND HE HAS TO
PROTECT THIS COUNTRY.
>> JOEL, YOUR REACTION.
>> I BELIEVE THAT WE COULD FIND
THE $100 MILLION ON SPENDING THE
TROOPS TO SEND IT TO THE
COUNTRIES THE HELP STABILIZE
THEM.
>> Neil: YOU DON'T BELIEVE
THERE'S A NATIONAL --
>> I BELIEVE OUR AGENTS FROM DHS
ARE CAPABLE OF HANDING THIS.
WE DON'T NEED TROOPS AT THE
BORDER NOW BEING AUTHORIZED TO
SHOOT AT A CARAVAN.
MAJORITY OF THEM ARE WOMEN AND
CHILDREN IN CAMPS.
>> IT'S NOT ALL WOMEN AND
CHILDREN --
>> THE MAJORITY ARE.
>> YOU HAVE PEOPLE WITH WEAPONS.
THEY'RE BEING ARRESTED BY THE
TIJUANA GOVERNMENT.
>> AND THE POLICE CAN HANDER
THAT.
AN ORDERLY PROCESS.
A PROCESS IN PLACE IS WORKING
AND SHOULD WORK.
WE DON'T NEED MILITARY TROOPS
THERE TO ENFORCE THE PROCESS
THAT IS ALREADY BEING EXECUTED
PROPERLY.
>> DONALD, YOUR THOUGHTS?
DO WE NEED THE TROOPS OR NOT?
OR IS TRUMP PLAYING FAST AND
LOOSE HERE?
>> NO, WE NEED THE TROOPS.
CBP IS 80% UNDERMANNED.
IF THE TROOPS CAN SUPPORT THEM
SO THE OFFICERS CAN DO THEIR
JOB, IT'S IMPORTANT.
IF THEY'RE OBSERVING AND
PROVIDING SUPPORT, LET THEM DO
THEIR JOBS SO THEY CAN DO WHAT
THEY'RE HIRED TO DO.
>> I'LL GIVE YOU A SHOT AT THIS.
SHOULD THE PRESIDENT CLOSE THE
BORDER DOWN?
DOES HE HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO DO
SO?
DONALD AND JOEL.
10 SECOND EACH.
>> WHETHER OR NOT HE SHOULD OR
SHOULD NOT, THAT REMAINS A
QUESTION AS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THE CARAVAN.
DOES HE HAVE THE AUTHORITY?
ABSOLUTELY.
IT'S HIS RIGHT TO DEFEND OUR
BORDERS AND PROTECT THE UNITED
STATES CITIZENS.
>> JOEL, IF HE BELIEVES THERE'S
A NATIONAL SECURITY THREAT,
CLEARLY HE CAN CLOSE DOWN THE
BORDER.
>> NATIONAL SECURITY THREAT
SHOULD BE DEALT WITH BUT IT'S AN
AMERICAN VALUE TO ALLOW PEOPLE